it's right now if you look at the news
you're not really hearing as much about
afghanistan as you know three months ago
you're going too soon i've been see i've
been busy i don't know what's going on
behind closing i don't just sit around
and wait for the media to call me yeah
so the last major media appearance i did
was on the 14th of september andrea
mitchell had me on her show
on i had just spent that morning
watching secretary blinken get hammered
by members of the house of
representatives and the day before he
had been before the senate and it was a
remember them it was abundantly clear to
anybody who watched we weren't getting
answers yeah we were getting kabuki
right we were they were using
afghanistan as a cudgel both sides were
retreating into their narrative
democrats were saying we did no wrong
republicans were saying you're the worst
thing ever and nobody was actually
getting to the bottom of what went wrong
and how do we prevent it from ever
happening again what would blinking the
worst part about that was he he seemed
as interested in the process he could he
was like it was performative he was just
there to like check a box right this is
the time that i come and get yelled at
and then this is it right that's how it
seemed to be it's like okay i've done my
two two days in the hot seat and that
was afghanistan yeah 20 years 2.2
trillion dollars
over
2600 americans killed in action over 21
000 americans injured not counting the
66 000 plus afghan
military members not even the civilians
who died in this war you don't just do
two days of hearings
so i said on tv she asked you know what
do you think of this and i just i spoke
the truth i said i think what was needed
was a 9 11 style commission
that was properly constituted to
in a bipartisan or even nonpartisan
nature investigate the entirety of the
afghanistan
it will now because guess what for the
last three months i have been very
quietly working this issue so tammy
duckworth saw me on andrea mitchell and
called me up
and said we agree we're writing
something called the afghan war
commission act of 2021 we need your help
they then had me call up uh some
republican members of the senate that i
know
uh and get them to jump on board to
co-sign and co-sponsor this this piece
of legislation and then i did the same
thing in the house of representatives so
much for those social circles buddy it
passed the house two weeks ago uh it's
in what's called the conference package
of the the the national defense
authorization act so the house has
already passed their version of the law
that funds the defense department for
the next year the senate is supposed to
be passing it at some point this week
it's considered non-controversial right
so it is going to absolutely pass when
the senate votes on this thing it's part
of the language that everyone already
agrees on that it's simply just they're
waiting for a vote as soon as the senate
votes on it it goes to the president's
desk and it will be signed and what this
is going to do is going to transform the
discussion on afghanistan
because this commission will exist for
the next four years it is going to be
it's modeled after the 911 commission so
it's eight republicans eight democrats
no one can be elected and be on the
commission at the same time you can't
hold federal office in any way no one
can be elected and be on the commission
at the same time correct so there's
nobody who's using it to like current
yeah politically granted
you're not using it to just get sound
bites to help with your next election it
is going to have this is what there's
never been anything like this in
american history it has the purview to
investigate the entirety of the afghan
war all 20 years
all four administrations all four white
houses all four intelligence communities
all four defense departments all four
people not happy about this and who's
happy about that i i would imagine that
if you served in uh in washington in the
last 20 years and worked on afghanistan
you're probably going to get called by
the commission at some point to testify
i some people are going to be thrilled
at that some people are going to
absolutely not want to give me names
like who's not going to be a happy
birthday i am i'm i'm positive probably
that jake sullivan in the white house uh
and mark and um for example ron klein
the current chiefs of staff probably are
not going to enjoy their time i am
absolutely positive the trump people are
not going to enjoy their time
particularly pompeo in front of this
commission right because this commission
is going to get to the bottom of things
it's going to figure out what went wrong
where did the war pivot why did we end
up losing because this isn't what
winning looks like most importantly at
least for me as a veteran
my hope is that what comes out of this
is policy and procedures that prevents
the chaos that we saw at the end of a
war from ever happening we have to
fundamentally change
how we go to and come home from war
so so let me let me give you uh a
cynical citizen's perspective on that i
mean that that's
it sounds good but at the same time for
my adult life i've lived and i've never
once seen
any politician outside of maybe ron
blagojevich ever held accountable for
anything that they've ever done true
i've never seen anybody in any capacity
that was a civilian contractor be held
accountable for anything they've done i
think i read once the out of the 2.2
trillion that we spent over two trillion
dollars went to civilian contractors i
mean that's i mean there's a lot of
people that became mega wealthy off of
this oh yeah and they profited immensely
off of this and we live in a society
where rich people don't go to jail so
what what does this hope to accomplish i
hear this and i say okay there's another
couple billion dollars about to be spent
on government lawyers there's another
you know years of of hand-wringing that
that's going to be done and at the end
of it nobody goes to jail at the end of
it nobody's held accountable it's the
panama papers it's i mean you know you
who went to jail for the panama papers
julian assange the guy who the guy who
was right about everything so i i mean
listen it's it's i'm not trying to
to dissuade you in any way from this no
no i could yeah nor could i but i just
fro from our perspective it's like man
yeah what do we do as citizens because
these people are never held accountable
this is what we do i know that look i
get it accountability begins with an
investigation it begins with shedding
light on what went wrong
so few americans actually know what
happened in afghanistan right
that
that this is where that accountability
begins
that word that you use accountability is
so important it's what veterans talk
about all the time right because at my
level in the military if i had [ __ ] up
i go to jail right i go to the brig i
get i get court-martialed i can i can be
punished
a general messes up they get to retire
and then go get a sit on a board
somewhere we bomb and we can't yeah we
kill seven people and they're like it's
an honest mistake as a buddy of mine
said the defense department regrets to
inform that your entire family has been
killed due to processes and procedures
not being properly followed like
come on yeah come on i i had a i had a i
had a buddy of mine and i had a buddy of
mine in afghanistan
i brought he held his like his feet to
the fire because of a fire fight in
which he'd call in an airstrike that
ended up killing some civilians right
and it was it was a legitimate airstrike
and his feet was held in the fire
because they weren't they wanted to make
absolutely sure that all the right
things were considered before they
dropped these bombs
these drone strikes that's the
difference now with warfare man if you
don't have people on the ground
identifying people you're just trying to
rely on some kid over in nellis air
force base in nevada to try to figure
out if the dude there is i mean they
killed the guy in afghanistan we're
talking about right now because he was
packing water jugs into his car
that's why he was killed it looked like
he was packing what they thought were
explosives it's called a war crime isn't
it it is it is and yet we don't we don't
hold anybody accountable this is how we
hold so what you're working on right now
is that public info do people know that
you're working on this or it's private
this is going to be public i mean i'm
telling you now first person there where
there will be a big media blitz about
this coming out i'm going to be tooting
my horn trust me because i i put my my
head down i i i to get this done this is
actually how [ __ ] gets done uh
in this country is these commissions
like think about it this way
my buddy paul rykov who is one of the
founders of an organization called the
iraq and afghan veterans of america
paul uh is an iraq war vet and he's
currently teaching a class at amherst
college his alma mater on 9 11. and
everyone in the class was born after 9
11 which to me is my boss yeah that's
interesting he said the most invaluable
teaching tool he has is the 911
commission report
i don't know if you've ever read it but
it's actually the most easily readable
government document ever made it reads
like a book it doesn't read like a
boring government document
we all lived through 9 11. i'm sure
for a lot of us myself included i can it
feels like i'm back there yesterday if i
talk about it right but my daughter who
was born in 2012 has no clue this is
going to be an invaluable resource for
her there's going to come a time in our
country's history where there are going
to be americans who who look at
afghanistan the same way some of us look
at like world war ii in korea and
vietnam we don't have a contextual
experience with it it's something that
our parents and grandparents did it's
something we read about right i'm hoping
that the report that comes out of this
is as invaluable to future generations
as the 9 11 commission because again
we've never done a post-mortem at the
end of a war like this we've never sat
down in the military we call it an
action review
the joke would be nobody's going home
until everybody gives me three positives
and two negatives right
right that that is that is what we're
gonna be doing now we're gonna be doing
a proper after action review of
everything that went right and wrong in
the war and this is good business
right because this helps us prepare for
the next war too so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you